der sommer aus dem ein winter wird
vielleicht ein besonders bitterer
wladimir putin lässt uns zittern der
herr über das gas und unser wohlbefinden
gibt es einen drinnen aus diesem
schicksal dazu bräuchte es eine extra
portion lockerheit und besonnenheit
gaskrise kommt der kalte winter jetzt in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns mal die
gäste zunächst zugeschaltet ist
professor michael hüther direktor am
institut oder des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft hier im studio ist
ursula weidenfeld
wirtschaftsjournalistin von beruf und
berufung frank werneke ist bei uns der
vorsitzende der gewerkschaft verdi und
schließlich muss sie sind mitglied der
geschäftsführung bei heinz klaas das ist
ein mittelständisches unternehmen in
oberfranken sie stellen flakons für
bisher aber die glasindustrie ist ja
wichtig auch für andere herstellungs-
bereiche herstellungs- arten und
besonders betroffen von der gaskrise
wieder gleich hören werden herr hüther
werten waren die wohnungen und eine
wettbewerbsfähige produktion in
deutschland zum luxusgut
also wenn wir davon ausgehen müssen dass
tut die tatsächlich nord stream 1 dann
nicht mehr in gang setzt dann haben wir
ein problem denn wir werden in vielen
bereichen die produktion einschränken
müssen es hängt davon ab wie der
bundesrat verteiler die
bundesnetzagentur funktioniert fungierte
als bundes last verteiler diese
verteilung der gasmengen vornimmt wir
werden ja zum winter hin noch keine lng
terminals schwimmende nutzbar haben das
heißt wir können in europa nur
umverteilt
und diese herausforderung glaube ich
steht greifbar im raum ob das passiert
das ist jetzt mehr profitiert als
prognose denn es hängt wirklich an den
handlungs überlegungen von putin und wir
können nur über die zeit hinein hoffen
dass das genug zeit für uns gibt die
anpassungen zu leisten wenn er sich
fortan ja mit verdi und den anderen
gewerkschaften hohe lohnabschlüsse und
weitere entlastungspaket um der
inflation zu trotzen das ist ja gut für
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer aber
möglicherweise nicht so gut für den
staatshaushalt und für bestimmte nicht
so kapitalstarke unternehmen
na ja wir haben eine situation wo wir
preisniveau haben von dem ausgehen
müssen dass es anhält wir sehen hier die
zahlen die die bundesbank zum beispiel
auch am montag im rahmen der
konzertierten aktion dargestellt hat
fast acht prozent inflationsrate in
diesem jahr aber auch über fünf prozent
im nächsten jahr und angesichts dieser
tatsache müssen wir als gewerkschaft
natürlich alles daran setzen dass die
einkommen unserer mitglieder mindestens
mal stabil bleiben und die entwicklung
der gaspreise sind eine ganz besondere
herausforderung für die wir dann auch
noch mal besondere maßnahmen diskutieren
das werden wir sicherlich gleich nochmal
vertiefen so weidenfeld die liquidität
im unternehmen ist sehr ungleich
verteilt
damit die schwächeren dieser unternehmen
die nicht so viel kapital zur verfügung
haben in dieser krise auch jetzt in
dieser energie krise nicht über die
klinge springen
braucht es da eine art neuer corona
hilfen gerade auch für unternehmen wir
werden sicherlich über
unternehmenshilfen diskutieren aber ich
glaube nicht dass es klug wäre noch mal
einen insolvenzschutz zu machen wie man
das in der korona pandemie gemacht hat
wir haben unternehmen die aus corona
jetzt praktisch in die gaskrise laufen
um die schon damals probleme hatten die
möglicherweise nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig sind und man kann es
drehen und wenden wie man will aber
rezession wirtschaftskrise sind nun mal
die zeiten in denen nicht
wettbewerbsfähige unternehmen aus dem
markt ausscheiden und in denen dann
arbeitnehmer
möglicherweise zu anderen unternehmen
wechseln können die im moment über
facharbeitermangel klagen und die das
wohl auch in zukunft tun werden insofern
glaube ich nicht dass es klug wäre eben
diesen corona dieses corona paket noch
mal genauso zu schnüren zumindest der
insolvenz united will
es wird mit sicherheit wenn abwenden wie
das worst-case-szenario annehmen wenn
die gaspreise sehr sehr hoch bleiben
wenn gas flüsse ausbleiben wenn
unternehmen am ende dann vom gas von der
gasversorgung ausgeschlossen werden dann
wird es zwar kompensationen geben aber
dann gibt es sicherlich insolvenzen
hergatz der ofen darf nie ausgehen
besonders nicht in der glasindustrie
sonst fällt nicht nur die produktion aus
sondern durch die besonderen technischen
eigenschaften der herstellung geht da
die anlage regelrecht kaputt hängt ihre
existenz die der glasindustrie am
seidenen faden
also wir sind ein sehr erfolgreiches
unternehmen gehören normalerweise nicht
zum unternehmen die insolvenz schutz
brauchen uns auch sagt bücher sind voll
wir haben keine kapazitäten frei aber
wenn kein gas mehr kommt das immer steht
nur greifend nicht in der lage unsere
anlagen zu betreiben die glasindustrie
hängt von den öffnen ab die 365 tage im
jahr laufen müssen wenn sie einmal
heruntergefahren sind dauert es falls
wir sie hoch fangen können mindestens 12
bis 18 monate vorausgesetzt werden das
personal das geht es wieder um die
notwendigen fachfirmen da die uns dabei
begleiten können also es ist eine sehr
angespannte situation ganz klar sie sind
ja jetzt sie stellen speziell flakons
für ein paar verse andere betriebe
oberfranken ist ja da ein
schwerpunkt in der glasindustrie
glasbehältnissen für die lebensmittel-
oder auch für die pharmazeutische
industrie also für die medizinische
versorgung das ist ja eine
systemische industrie was passiert wenn
sie nicht mehr in deutschland
produzieren können dann machen wir jetzt
auseinander das ist eine das ist eine
klare konsequenz wenn in deutschland ist
nicht mehr möglich ist wirtschaftlich zu
produzieren dann folgt der nächste
schritt und dann müssten wir quasi im
ausland weiter machen
herr hüther wenn putin sie haben gerade
schon angesprochen im juli dass die
wartungsarbeiten oder nach den
wartungsarbeiten bei nordstream 1 die da
jedes jahr stattfinden die leitung
abgedreht lässt also wenn wie man so
schön sagt eine politische wartung
eintritt
was was muss man dann als nächstes
machen auch aus ökonomischer sozialer
schicht sich das bei uns hier keine
panik eintritt denn dann geht er
wirklich noch mal sehr viel gas verloren
wenn wir eine solche feststellung
vornehmen müssen dass der gasimport nach
deutschland nicht mehr funktioniert eine
große lücke auftritt dann muss die
bundesnetzagentur die nächste warnstufe
auf alarmstufe ausgerufen und dann wird
es auch zu anderen maßnahmen in der
preissetzung kommen und es wird auch zur
verteilung
organisation kommen die wir bisher so
nicht kennen es wird ja vorgeschlagen
dass man beispielsweise für die
industrie dann mengen auktioniert man
wird schauen ob man im öffentlichen
bereich einfach auch schon vorsicht
vorsorglich für den herbst und winter
die temperaturen anpassen wir müssen an
vielen vielen stellen da etwas tun denn
wir können diese ausfallende menge
russischen gases kurzfristig das heißt
bis ins nächste aber auch das
übernächste jahr hinein nicht komplett
durch andere quellen ausgleichen selbst
wenn casas tanzes wie das wir haben gar
nicht diese pipeline systeme die das in
der wirklich ausfüllen können und
insofern ist das dann wird nicht eine
worst case situation wir hätten
produktionsausfälle ist es eben für die
glasindustrie genannt worden sie können
das weiterdenken für stahl für aber auch
die ernährungsindustrie für die
papierindustrie für viele andere und
dort haben wir im grunde existenzfragen
und die existenz fragen sind genauso zu
sehen wie es eben angedeutet wurde wenn
sie in deutschland aufgrund der
versorgungslage im grunde dann für
längere zeit keine produktions
perspektive haben dann wird man das land
verlassen und dann werden wir hier nicht
nur eine möglichkeit oder eine
freisetzung von beschäftigten haben die
anderen nutzen können so wir werden dann
was arbeitslosigkeit haben und das ist
die große sorge die ich habe wir haben
wenig stellschrauben das wirklich
kurzfristig zu kompensieren ich hatte es
angedeutet weil wir einfach diese
infrastruktur neu aufbauen müssen selbst
wenn wir zwei terminals findet zum
jahreswechsel nutzbar haben das ist
wirklich dann sehr optimistisch gedacht
bleibt einfach eine lücke und das wird
einige sehr erheblich treffen dann haben
wir die folgewirkungen wenn glas
beispielsweise fehlt hat das ja
konsequenzen nicht nur bei flakons und
dann bei der bereitstellung von
nahrungsmitteln im einzelhandel oder von
bestimmten medikamenten
insofern hat das weitreichende
kaskadeneffekt die man sich beim glas
und stahl bei den anderen bereichen
nicht nannte sich leicht vorstellen kann
sehen dass einige sachen angesprochen
die den wir gleich noch genauer
untersuchen wir wollen uns aber vor
weiterhin studio diskutieren zwei
grafiken ansehen die das deutlich machen
es geht nämlich um unsere abhängigkeit
aus russland die gas flüsse die über 31
punkte die deutsche grenze überqueren
wir gucken uns sagen die beiden oberen
anders ist
waidhaus das ist an der bayerisch
tschechischen grenze und das ist
greifswald und hier sehen wir in beiden
in beiden kurven dass sie etwas so mitte
juni doch ziemlich auffällig stark nach
unten ging das war diese situation als
russland den gas transport nach europa
schon gedrosselt hat also hier sieht man
einen ziemlichen knick und was das
bedeutet wenn russisches gas
in einer solchen weise reduziert wird
wie in diesen beiden kurven die dann
nach unten gehen dann zeigen wir ihnen
auf der nächsten grafik seite was das
bedeutet 53 prozent unseres gases
beziehung auf russland aus norwegen
schon sehr viel weniger aus den
niederlanden
alle anderen können wir vernachlässigen
das heißt wenn russland die gasmenge
reduziert oder den gashahn ganz ab dreht
dann bedeutet das massive konsequenzen
vielleicht sollten wir auch weniger noch
mal schauen was das für die einzelnen
bedeutet plötzlich weniger energie zur
verfügung zu haben die folge ist ja
unter anderem dass der gaspreis und
wahrscheinlich auch die anderen
energiepreise durch die decke schießen
man redet von einer verdreifachung
erkennen sich fast mit forderungen nach
lohnausgleich oder vier fraktionen
inflationsausgleich gar nicht mehr nach
und als erstes wissen wir nicht was mit
den gaslieferungen passiert weil es ja
auch sein kann dass nach dem ende der
revision von nord stream an
am 16 juli wieder gas fließt und dann zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt das
damoklesschwert was über uns hängt fällt
oder auch nicht von daher sind wir da
auf einer situation sind wenn der
situation wo unbekannte im raum ist los
aber auch sagen die fatale abhängigkeit
vom russischen gas ist ja spätestens mit
dem überfall russlands auf die ukraine
erkannt worden und es sind maßnahmen
ergriffen worden das heißt das ist ja
alles daran gesetzt worden die
gasspeicher voll zu bekommen aber heute
hat vollkommen recht sollte die
lieferungen aus russland komplett
ausfallen dann tritt die dritte
warnstufe in kraft und dann haben wir
nicht nur ein preis problem wie wir es
derzeit haben sondern wir haben menges
problem dafür gibt es klare regeln das
ist dann als erstes die versorgung der
privaten haushalte von schulen
krankenhäusern und ähnlichen dingen
sicher zu stellen und dann das rare gut
was überbleibt durch die
bundesnetzagentur an die industrien die
sich
weigern werden um die kapazitäten dann
weitergegeben es gibt sicherlich
möglichkeiten auch nochmal den privaten
verbrauch dann einzuschränken was auch
jetzt schon sinnvoll ist aber die
auswirkungen sind oder die möglichkeiten
das zu regulieren sind begrenzt man
sieht ja dass das eben schon im
gasverbrauch total gespart wird also ist
es ja nicht so als wäre der westen oder
als wären wir nur ausgeliefert der
gasverbrauch ist in diesem jahr schon um
fast 15 prozent zurückgegangen das heißt
es wird schon gespart und es gibt
offenbar auch luft zum sparen und wenn
man sich halt eben anschaut wie viel gas
wie immer noch benutzen um strom
herzustellen da ist eben auch ganz viel
drin und da hat ja die bundesregierung
bereits beschlossen kohlekraftwerke
länger laufen zu lassen um eben den
gasanteil in der stromproduktion runter
zu fahren das kann man möglicherweise
noch weiter tun möglicherweise werden ja
auch die drei atomkraftwerke noch ein
bisschen länger laufen die wir haben um
eben den strommarkt zu entlasten da ist
schon noch was drin und
ich glaube man muss nicht alles jetzt
ragen schwarz malen ist muss nicht
schiefgehen
kann ja auch nicht so sein dass man sich
am ende wegen seiner sanktionen und
seiner sanktionsdrohungen haben
demjenigen den man eigentlich bestrafen
wollte total ausliefert aber es ist
wichtig die sanktionen die dazu führen
dass das gas nicht kommen sondern es ist
der putin setzt den was die gas als
liefer- und letztendlich als als waffe
ein massine ja auch getan haben
wie dem auch sei natürlich gibt es
vielerlei möglichkeiten und nochmal zu
regen ist steht bereits fest dass die
verstromung aus gas praktisch
eingestellt wird das alles hat effekte
trotzdem würde es nicht nur ein preis
problem geben sondern grundlegend mit
schwierigkeiten die dann zu händeln sind
die auch nicht das ende aller tage sind
aber eine große herausforderung schon
was ich
gerade gesagt das ist ja erkannt jetzt
seitdem der ukraine krieg begonnen hat
was bei uns alles auf uns zukommen
könnte das was jetzt an präventiven
maßnahmen dieser notfallplan
entwickelt worden ist ist das schon
vermittelt da schon das gefühl dass die
regierung die lage einigermaßen im griff
hat dass sie das richtige gemacht dass
sie die vorsorgemaßnahmen die prävention
richtig setzt ich glaube im moment kann
niemand so tun als hätten wir alles im
griff wir haben ja nicht nur ein
mengenproblem und ein preis problem wir
haben auch ein verteilungsproblem wir
haben ja nicht die richtigen pipelines
um dafür zu sorgen dass man dann im
winter alle regionen in deutschland
gleich gut oder gleich schlecht mit gas
versorgen kann und da ist eben einfach
noch sehr sehr viel zu tun bis zum
winter
mein eindruck ist schon dass die
bundesregierung die dramatik der lage
erkannt hat dass die bundesnetzagentur
einen sehr kommunikativen und auch sehr
handlungsfähigen chef hat und dass da
schon alles getan wird und die erwägung
gezogen wird was man tun kann und in
erwägung ziehen kann abgesehen davon
dass wir uns immer noch sehr sehr schwer
tun das thema atomkraft anzugucken und
eben zu überlegen ob man nicht diese
drei kraftwerke die noch da sind länger
laufen lässt möglicherweise über diesen
winter oder über die nächsten zwei drei
jahre in denen gas sehr sehr knapp sein
wird das hilft aber der industrie die
gasverbrauch nicht weiter aber es hilft
bei der stromproduktion die
stromproduktion ist angesichts der kohle
kapazitäten vorhanden sind nicht das
problem ja aber die stromproduktion wird
das problem werden wenn man nämlich um
das ist ja sowieso zweit und dritt
runden effekt aber wenn man jetzt ganz
viel kohle verfeuert dann braucht man
ganz viele emissionszertifikate um diese
kohle herum um die den co2 ausstoß zu
und zu kaufen oder muss man später
regeln klimaabkommen sind dann auch gar
nicht mehr ein sondern ganz kurz sie
sind stark von von gaslieferungen
abhängig haben sie da schon probleme
gehabt oder läuft das im moment noch
ganz gut oder was sagt es jährlich
gasversorger lieferant ihnen für die
nächste zeit voraus läuft es läuft
tatsächlich gut also wir haben keinerlei
probleme gehabt
kurzfristig wären wahrscheinlich auch
keine probleme bekommt unser
gasversorger kann auch nicht mehr sagen
als allgemein bekannt also wir wissen
nicht ob das kommt im winter es hängt
alles vom putin ab wir wissen nicht ob
er das gas abstellen oder weshalb erst
eventuell abstellt oder ob er es
überhaupt nicht abstellt das wissen wir
einfach nicht wir wissen aber dass wir
es gas benötigen bei uns in der
industrie ist es nicht möglich halt
schwanger zu sein das heißt wir
produzieren oder wir produzieren nicht
wir haben 365 tage im jahr eine
produktion laufen und eine glasschmelze
war eine braucht permanent energie
das heißt wenn das gas nicht mehr kommt
sind wir auch ganz schnell mit dem
produktion heruntergefahren ich würde
gleich gerne noch darüber mit ihnen
weiter reden herr hüther es gibt ja in
diesen notfallplan eine spezielle von
vielen gefürchtete klausel die
preisanpassungsklausel das heißt wir
diese dritte stufe die notfall stufe
jetzt gezündet wird die alarmstufe dann
können die kosten die die gasimporteure
haben beim erwerb von gas auf dem
weltmarkt weiter gegeben werden zunächst
an die versorger und von dort aus dann
an die endkunden dass es wie gesagt es
wird ja vom dreifachen möglicherweise
energiepreise im vergleich zum nächsten
jahr gesprochen kann der starter beim
sozialen ausgleich für die die wenig
haben mithalten bei solchen
preissprüngen und dazu vorliegen bei
einer solchen unberechenbarkeit was dann
passieren könnte denn dass die preise
nach oben gehen ist klar die mengen sind
verknappt die preise steigen ja zunächst
noch ein hinweis wir haben im augenblick
ein anteil des russischen gases von 35
prozent also es in der tat eine
deutliche anpassung schon eingetreten
das sollte man auch nicht vergessen und
ein zweiter punkt der auch nochmals so
lage wichtig ist wir versorgen auch
österreich oder und die slowakei
beispielsweise mit die haben gar keine
andere möglichkeit habe bisher kaum
vorsorge getroffen das heißt dass es in
die ganzen rechnungen nicht drin
insofern ist die verknappung situation
möglicherweise viel schärfer als wie sie
augenblicklich sehen aber in diesen
ländern beispielsweise der speicher
haidach in tirol überhaupt nicht bisher
angemessen befüllt wurde dass sie nicht
weit unter den knapp 60 prozent die wir
hier erreicht haben und das ist ein
punkt der in deutschland gerne übersehen
wird die frage der preisanpassung es
gibt zwei regeln dazu der das ist dieser
paragraph 24 § 26 der preismechanismus
das in der tat die preise wie sie es
beschrieben am weitergegeben werden oder
im sinne einer umlage also es kann das
eine das andere konzept gewählt werden
die bundesregierung versucht bisher was
ich der übergangsphase auch richtig
finden um die preisschocks nicht noch so
verstärken dass ein bisschen außen vor
zu lassen und im grunde eine abfederung
der energie und der betreffen
unternehmen wie juniper wir gerade das
in der nähe neben konnte organisiert
letztlich ist das ein beitrag den
preisschock etwas abzumildern der dann
irgendwann zweifellos auch kommen wird
aber da wir morgen diese unsicherheit
nicht haben ob nicht möglicherweise dann
ende juli die sache dann besser aussieht
weil putin doch den gashahn wieder
geöffnet hat und wir sowohl über nutzt
den einst als auch die anderen leitungen
etwas nach deutschland die lieferung
bekommen möglicherweise auch nach füllen
können dann ist es gut die in dieser
übergangsphase erst einmal von diesem
preis anpassungsmechanismen abzusehen
also die entscheidende phase ist
eigentlich dann im herbst und geht dann
in das jahr 2023 hinein der zweite ist
das politisch richtig in dieser un-
sicherheitsrat ein mal von diesem
preisanpassungen noch abzusehen und er
die unternehmen diese verteilung
vornehmen die in den weltmärkten
unterwegs sind zu stabilisieren ich
sollte vielleicht nochmal uns eine
weitere grafik ansehen und zwar es geht
ja auch darum wer welches gas braucht
verbraucht haushalte industrie sonstige
gasproduzenten beziehungsweise gas ab
hier haben wir das wofür in deutschland
gas genutzt wird der relativ größte teil
das ist industrie gewerbe handel
dienstleistungen dann die
privathaushalte fast die hälfte der
deutschen haushalte werden ja mit gas
der privathaushalte beheizt für die
stromversorgung dieser gelbe balken der
wird vielleicht etwas schmaler werden
wenn kohlekraftwerke zur
kohleverstromung in aktion treten werden
das gehört ja auch zur vorsorge
maßnahmen möglicherweise plus die drei
vorhandenen atomkraftwerke noch etwas
länger laufen und allen konflikten gehen
dann in die fernwärme ja wenn wir das
jetzt gesehen haben
die
dass die industrie besonders davon
betroffen ist es gibt ja ein vorschlag
eines industrieverbandes diese
priorisierung als erstes die
privathaushalte zu versorgen und dann
erst die industrie und damit
arbeitsplätze zu sichern etwas
abzuwandeln so nach dem prinzip
überfrieren als arbeitslos wie sehen sie
diese priorisierung der
bundesnetzagentur erst werden die
privathaushalte die sozialen
einrichtungen pflege und krankenhäuser
versorgt und dann die industriebetriebe
sollte man da etwas flexibler handeln
also wie ich denke das ist grundsätzlich
wichtig weil es ist entscheidend auch
wenn ein land wie deutschland das
soziale frieden herrscht aber wir dürfen
bei alldem nicht vergessen dass es auch
dass deutschland industriestaat ist dass
deutschland industrienationen ist das
heißt wir müssen damit der verbleibenden
menge wie ist frau auf ein feld gesagt
hat sehen wen tun wir dann noch
versorgung mit gas und da muss man genau
hinschauen welche industrien können denn
auf gas verzichten zumindest eine
zeitlang bei welchen industrien können
wir das nicht machen und da geht dann
die eigentliche verteidigung nur so ja
ich finde es auch richtig die privaten
haushalte von sozialen einrichtungen wie
krankenhäuser und ähnliches sollten
sollten zuerst versorgt werden eventuell
mit einer kleinen einsparungen da
womöglich weil alkohol wird ja auch
schon eingespart wie wir gesehen haben
und da muss man ganz genau hinschauen
wem kann ich dennoch die restmenge zur
verfügung stellen also wozu ich einen
bleibenden schaden verhindern wenn dann
überhaupt eine restmenge noch da ist
herr werneke wenn die nachfrage höher er
ist als das angebot also diese dann wird
es ein hauen und stechen geben um das
gas
was erwarten sie dass da auch
vorkehrungsmaßnahmen oder wie sollten
die alle beteiligten politik die
gewerkschaften die industrie aber eben
auch die privathaushalte also alle
menschen die in dieser gesellschaft
eigentlich da am besten reagieren was
können sie erwarten wie sollten sie sich
verhalten was muss man oder wie muss die
politik da gerade in dieser
verteilungsfrage das krisen management
organisieren nach den jetzigen
erkenntnissen und ohne dass das worst
case szenario eintritt muss davon
ausgegangen werden dass die preise für
gas sich im verhältnis zum jahr 2021
verdreifacht und für strom verdoppeln
und der hüter darauf hingewiesen die
frage ist ja zu welchem zeitpunkt und in
welcher dimension tritt diese
preiserhöhung in kraft ist es vollkommen
richtig derzeit den liquiditätsbedarf
der stadtwerke wie aber auch der
einkaufenden unternehmen zu sichern und
das ist eine große herausforderung und
dann zu überlegen ob man mit einer
umlage die auch zeitlich gestreckt wird
wo auch über darlehens regelungen des
streckung stattfinden kann den aufprall
ab zu mindern und dass man so zu
formulieren aber am ende sind die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher mit
höheren gas und strompreisen
konfrontiert und darauf wird die politik
noch mal reagieren müssen denn das sind
belastungen für vierköpfige familien
wenn ich mal die jahre 22 und 23
zusammen nehme ohne dass es einen
importstopp gibt aus russland bereits
von mehreren tausend euro erreicht wird
der jetzigen hilfspakete die in die
richtige richtung gehen nicht aus und
deshalb ist aus meiner sicht weitere
maßnahmen notwendig auch maßnahmen die
insbesondere dann in 23 wirken weil dort
werden die dinge aufschlagen was halten
sie von diesem satz lieber frieren als
arbeitslos ich finde das ist ein
falsches bild was da aufgemacht wird es
gibt klare europäische regelungen wo
klar ist dass privathaushalte schulen
krankenhäuser und so weiter und so fort
zuerst zu bedienen sind man kann alles
versuchen und muss daran setzen dass in
den bereichen energie gespart wird da
sind wir auch als gewerkschaften dabei
aber es wäre völlig falsch die sind
priorität des riten system zu verändern
es wird auch kurzfristig gar nicht sein
das ist auch nicht national zu lösen und
dann ist es aber ja auch so dass dann
kein gas mehr da ist sondern das ist
eine restmenge von gas da oder teile ich
ihnen stimme ich vollkommen zug muss
klar priorisiert werden in welcher
reihenfolge dann die dinge und zwar
nicht nach dem motto wer bezahlt am
meisten sondern wo es die notwendigkeit
am größten die konzentrierung
stattfindet und das ist mit der
bundesnetzagentur auch möglich dass sich
allerdings dann nicht verstehe ist wenn
wenn wir wissen und das ist da ist ja
totaler konsens dass privathaushalte
soziale einrichtungen dass die zuerst
und prioritäten gas bekommen was ich
nicht verstehe ist warum man dann eben
vorschläge gar nicht diskutiert die eben
zum beispiel darum gehen haushalten die
besonders viel sparen oder die eben für
sich diese abwägung machen lieber ein
bisschen frieren als eben mein
arbeitgeber oder überhaupt unternehmen
insgesamt in gefahr zu bringen warum man
sich dann eben solchen diskussionen
verweigert das wenn die industrie nicht
benötigte mengen zurück gibt dann werden
die auktioniert und man die die
unternehmen werden dafür belohnt ich
finde ja die haushalte müssten dafür
auch belohnt werden also warum herr berg
dann sagt christen nicht alter wenn es
eigentlich doch darum geht
unternehmen familien oder oder haushalte
die sich vernünftig verhalten die
vielleicht auch mehr tun als sie
unbedingt müssten denen eben auch zu
signalisieren das wird wertgeschätzt das
ist von nicht nur vernünftig und klug
und staatstragend sondern es wird eben
auch belohnt mein eindruck ist dass wir
uns diesen schönen tieren während dem
der preis dann auch geringer ist also
wir müssen jetzt nicht aber die falschen
dinge hier diskutiert die privaten
haushalte sehen sie in ihren wirkungen
ja erst im nachhinein das sehen sie dann
bei der nächsten abrechnung sie können
die er nicht laufend irgendwie irgendwas
entschädigen wir können bei den privaten
haushalten nur durch ansprache durch
hinweis und natürlich müssen sie auch
die preise auch ein stück reagieren ein
beitrag leisten aber wir wissen die ein
strenges hinterher und das macht das
problem ja so deutlich wir können ja in
der anfangs verteilung nur von dem
ausgehen was wir wissen dass haushalte
zuletzt verbraucht haben also bleibt
dann die restmenge alles das was private
haushalte einsparen können ist natürlich
wichtig aber wir wissen das vom effekt
es hinterher und das entlastet uns bei
der planung nicht die bundesnetzagentur
muss vorher entscheidungen treffen und
in jeder der ein staat hat ja auch eine
einsparung also ist ja auch nicht so
dass die unternehmen wenn sie einsparen
wenn sie innovationen geleistet haben
uns geht ganz ganz viele die zu uns
unterwegs sind versuchen wo sie leichter
hand als andere das ist wir haben über
die glasproduktion muss man da geht's
halt nicht oder anderen geht es
möglicherweise dann haben die auch eine
einsparung aber es wird ja nicht jeder
gleich belohnt wir sind hier in der
gesamtverantwortung wo alle glaube ich
ihren beitrag leisten müssen und die
haushalte auch das muss man noch mal
sagen weil gelegentlich das habe ich mal
auf schloss der wirtschaft gehört ja
dann muss man ja die privaten haushalte
der abt knappen das geht nicht sie
können nicht die gasversorgung der
privaten haushalte abdrehen und sagen
wir drehen die mal wieder hoch dann
müssen sie bei jedem sich anschauen was
der für ein ventil zu hause hat sonst
fliegt uns alles um die ohren also auch
das muss man ganz nüchtern mit bedenken
das ist einfach der rahmen wir sind
einer mist situation und jetzt müssen
wir gucken dass wir da auch gemeinsam
mit vernunft rauskommen aber nicht mit
irgendwelchen albernen dingen die jetzt
noch mit prämien aus ich habe heute dass
es falsch ist das als alba zu bezeichnen
wenn man sagt es gibt dinge und mich an
das die technische störung zu hören wenn
es wenn man sagt es gibt dinge und
mechanismen die funktionieren gut in der
wirtschaft und wenn man sagt aber
ständige appelle an freiwilligkeit das
verbraucht sich ja auch und das ist auch
irgendwann vorbei für die preise häufig
aber den preis merken die privaten
haushalte ja auch als später und wenn
man wenn man dann instrumente hat und
möglicherweise
wirksame instrumente hat dann finde ich
kann man es sich nicht leisten das als
albernheit abzutun
in der planung nicht berücksichtigen
können das ist das problem die
bundesnetzagentur muss in einer gas
mangel lage entscheidungen treffen und
sie kann er nicht prognosen anstellen
dass die privaten haushalte auf diese
prämien so oder so reagieren also ich
glaube wir verkämpfen uns da völlig an
der falschen stelle es muss darum gehen
die effizienzvorteile in der
volkswirtschaft insgesamt zu nutzen und
viel mehr zu schauen wo unternehmen
beispiel leisten können die
energieintensiv sind durch andere
technologien von gas unabhängig zu
werden das muss ausgerollt werden dann
haben wir den eigentlichen knackpunkt
nämlich in der industrie am besten
gehandelt und das braucht aber ein stück
zeit so dass sich die frage wie viel
zeit haben dafür und die zeit gewinnen
wir auch nicht wenn wir darauf warten
noch prämien ausloben das ist bei den
privaten haushalten hinterher es zu
messen weil sie ja immer monatsweise
oder quartalsweise wirklich wissen was
die weniger gebraucht gutes technisches
problem not macht erfinderisch die frage
welche alternativen möglichkeiten gibt
so lassen sie auch ein beispiel dafür
sie versuchen ja jetzt vom gas weg zu
kommen weil sie diese unglaubliche
abhängigkeit auch haben das versuchen
die produktion zu elektrifizieren das
haben sie auch vor allerdings wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe fehlen ja noch
jede menge technischer voraussetzungen
und möglichkeiten also das was da an
konstellation an design her muss das ist
ja noch gar nicht da also wir haben nach
dem überfall überfall russlands auf die
ukraine einen radikalen beschluss
gefasst die geschäftsführung die inhaber
wir gehen von einer gasbetriebenen warne
weg anders aus statt olympia zu zwei
elektrisch betriebenen wann müssen dabei
auf technologien setzen die noch nicht
fertig entwickelt worden sind ich weiß
jetzt nicht wie gut wie viel da noch
fehlt aber wir müssen auch diese
technologien setzen
die operation am offenen herzen die
operation am offenen herzen das heißt
die aktuelle glas panne wird im heißen
zustand repariert damit sie bis mitte
nächsten jahres hält und ab da werden
wir das elektrifizierte waren umstellen
aber das ist eine also nicht nur die
weine sondern die komplette
infrastruktur des betriebes das heißt
wir werden nach unserer kenntnis
weltweit der erste glashersteller der
die glasschmelze ohne fossile energie
betreibt wird dazu notwendig ist
allerdings sei mit einer zweistelligen
millionenbetrag und den leisten zu
können dann als familienunternehmen als
mittelständler ist natürlich äußerst
schwierig und ich denke wenn der staat
sich mehr auf solche investitionen
konzentrieren würde und da die förderung
gezielter und vor allem direkter
durchführt ist viel mehr geholfen als
wenn
geld für einmalige effekte ausgeglichen
eigentlich ja auch ein beispiel für
andere energieintensive industrie ich
glaube die vier glas betriebe in ihrer
gegend verbrauchen so viel gas wie
85.000 einfamilienhäuser im jahr und so
viel strom wie eine stadt mit 400.000
einwohnern das ist eine enorme kapazität
wie gesagt ist ein vier betriebe in der
ländlichen gegend von oberfranken was
müssten eigentlich die ganzen in den
energieintensiven unternehmen tun jetzt
macht oder anders gefragt machen sie
genügend
ist eine frage der technologie also wir
können natürlich nicht beliebig
elektrifizieren das ist immer die frage
ist es überhaupt möglich steht erst in
zehn jahren zur verfügung
also selbst wenn wir die bahn
elektrifizieren was wir jetzt machen
werden müssen wir nicht was das für
strom das kann natürlich auch seiner
grünen quelle kommt wird es aber
wahrscheinlich nicht das heißt wir
müssen den den ausbau der energie der
erneuerbaren energien massiv und schnell
auch schnell vorantreiben da haben wir
keine zeit und wir dürfen uns seit ich
von irgendwelchen bürokratischen
hindernissen aufhalten das ist dann
müssen wir flexibel sein ich denke auch
es darf keine denkverbote gehen egal in
welche richtungen also sie haben freunde
atomkraft zum beispiel angesprochen oder
kohlekraft kohlekraftwerke als es darf
in der aktuellen situation meiner
meinung nach keine denkverbote geben und
da muss sich unter wert sich glaube ich
auch die bundesregierung trauen an
solche themen anzugehen damit die
industrien die er dann in einer
gasanlage als letztes bedient werden
auch die chance bekommen zumindest so
weit wie möglich zu kommen ohne gas
damit sie transformationen
vorangetrieben werden kann und dafür
aber wirklich notwendig ist nicht dieses
energiekosten dämpfungs programm was
schön und gut ist was aber unserer
meinung nach nicht nicht so sehr helfen
wird weil da eben unternehmen
unterstützt werden die den es schon
deutlich schlechter geht was sie
eingangs erwähnt habe sondern ich denke
wir sollten die unternehmen gefordert
werden die jetzt bereit sind die
transformation anzugehen die jetzt
bereits im geld in die hand zu nehmen
den muss geholfen werden den sollte
geholfen dann haben einen schritt nach
vorne gemacht auch nachhaltig ist es
gibt ja auch noch einen anderen
vorschlag nämlich ein sogar gaspreis
deckel für industrie und privathaushalte
einzuführen den gibt es ja in einigen
ländern ich glaube in spanien portugal
und italien ist das eine möglichkeit
eine brückentechnologie eine
gesellschaftspolitische
brückentechnologie ich glaube
gesellschaftspolitisch ist es
tatsächlich einen vorschlag den man
diskutieren muss aber
industriepolitisch würde man ja dann um
rationierung und preissetzung nicht drum
herum kommen und das eben schon im
vorfeld also dann würde man ja man teilt
jedem einen bestimmten verbrauch zu
einem bestimmten preis zu und alles was
darüber geht wird dann eben anders
bezahlt ich glaube
sehr dass das findet für die praxis
privathaushalte nicht wirklich für dich
auch nicht sicher ob es für die
privathaushalte funktioniert weil man ja
das preissignal braucht man muss ja
wissen es ist verdammt teuer
wir reden ja die ganze zeit darüber dass
man diese gasrechnung eben
wahrscheinlich erst im nächsten jahr
bekommt es sei denn die
bundesnetzagentur gibt eben jetzt das
frei dass die preise weitergereicht
werden aber letztlich ich bin ganz bei
ihnen das dass man privathaushalte nicht
ins elend stürzen darf nur weil sie ihre
energie rechnungen nicht bezahlen können
aber sie müssen wissen was die
energierechnung ist und wenn man eben
hingehen würde und ebenso ein preis
deckel darauf setzt oder eine ration und
und rationiert dann verfälscht man
dieses preissignal und dann verstehen
viele verbraucher nicht warum die lage
dramatisch ist insofern ich bin bin
wirklich überhaupt nicht dagegen dass
man haushalte die ihre gasrechnung ihre
stromrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen können
dass man da etwas tut und ich glaube
auch dass man etwas tun muss ich glaube
nur dass eben rationierung und preis
deckelung eben einfach das falsche
das falsche signal senden mit beliebig
vielen fällt aber andererseits ist es
auch einen wettbewerbsnachteil für die
industrie wenn andere länder von in der
europäischen union bereits ohne
preisobergrenze haben siehe frankreich
das ist für die industrie eine ein
wettbewerbs-nachteil und wenn es andere
länder tun können dann können sie
zumindest darüber machen müssen wir die
nicht auch machen und das haben wir bei
unserer band das ist quatsch das ist ein
wettbewerbsnachteil und am ende leidet
den musikstandort deutschland also
einmal sorgen für gleich regeln überall
oder wir werden flexibel überall wir
können jetzt nicht nur weil nur weil es
grundsätzlich falsch ist da gebe ich
ihnen recht können wir nicht darauf
verzichten weil es ist am ende ein
wettbewerbs-nachteil freunden gegenüber
frankreich spanien usw da klappert haben
sie recht aber hält mein eindruck vom
zustand der bevölkerung ist ein
vollkommen anderer und ich bin wirklich
viel unterwegs und wird angeschrieben
und bin in veranstaltung da ist die
sorge abflug gegenwärtig was da passiert
es ist vollkommen klar dass der riesige
rechnung rechnung kommt niemand ins
blaue hinein und sagt ich warte mal ab
und das wird dann schon irgendwie nicht
so kommen das ist ein ganz hohes
verantwortungsbewusstsein und ich finde
schon dass die bevölkerung mit ganz
normalen einkommen eine möglichkeit
haben muss
bezahlbare sich über diesen winter zu
bringen und das nicht und deshalb ist
der vorschlag zu sagen also eine
vierköpfige familie braucht verbraucht
ungefähr 12.000 kilowattstunden dass das
preislich auf dem niveau von 21
garantiert wird damit es eben nicht
diese notsituation gibt das ist teuer
aber der tank hat hat auch milliarden
gekostet das ist besser investiertes
geld als langwasser nicht ich glaube
dass es jetzt darauf ankommt dass
diejenigen die ihre gasrechnung nicht
bezahlen können dass man denen hilft und
nicht dass man mittelstandsfamilien die
ihre gasrechnung auch noch bezahlen
können wenn sie dreimal so hoch ist das
tut natürlich weh und das ist für
niemanden ein spaß aber man muss doch in
einem land das in eine rezession läuft
und das wirklich begrenzte spielräume
hat auch begrenzte finanzielle
spielräume hat man muss doch gar nicht
mittelstandsfamilien und
besserverdienenden helfen mit einem gas
kontingents um zum sonderrabatt die das
nicht brauchen aber dann hat er dann in
die rezession wenn die kaufkraft
nachlässt und sie würde was
eingeschränkt werden wir haben im moment
kein nachfrageprobleme wernecke wir
haben ein angebotsproblem das einzige
was derzeit die konjunktur stabilisiert
ist die stabile nachfrage und die gilt
es zu stabilisieren ich kenne die
nachfrage ist deshalb stabil weil wir
eine gute beschäftigungslage haben auf
dem wenn das ins rutschen kommt wenn der
eindruck entsteht wir laufen eine
rezession die arbeitsplätze gefährdet
und auch von den rahmenbedingungen her
noch in dieser prozess unterstützt wird
dann glaube ich stehen wir von der
anderen frage dann ist nicht nur
kaufkraft sicherung das thema sondern
nach dem nachfrageeinbruch eine völlig
andere lage also das muss man auch sehen
ich bin auf einen anderen punkt
hinweisen das deutet vor weidenfeller
indirekt an wir erleben ja einen
wohlstands abschluss ans ausland weil
wir gas das wir importieren einfach
anders bezahlen müssen ökonomen nennen
dass der terms of trade effekt das heißt
dann perfekt wird negativ das können wir
nicht komplett ausbuchen oder nur zu
sagen sonst für die in die zukunft
verschieben sondern wir müssen sehr
genau schauen welche haushalte sind in
einer not aber auch welche unternehmen
sind in einer note das ist die gleiche
situation wir wollen ja die gesamtlage
einigermaßen stabilisiert und da glaube
ich muss man wirklich sehr schauen ob
nicht ähnliche dinge wie
heizkostenpauschale der
heizkostenzuschuss gebe es auch schon
1974 nach der ersten ölkrise eingesetzt
wurde als instrument der jetzt im
frühjahr schon einmal gemacht wo das man
sich das sehr genau anschaut das kann
man mit dem wohngeld beziehen das kann
man auch ein bisschen anders fassen man
muss sich anschauen wie man
rentnerhaushalte mit in den blick nimmt
und nicht erwerbstätige aber ich glaube
die frage ist in der tat immer zu messen
an der situation der haushalte kommen
sie mit der situation zurecht sodass es
leidlich geht oder kommen sie nicht
zurecht und sind unverschuldet einer
schwierigen lage und das kriegen wir
besser im griff da bin ich ganz bei frau
weidenfeld wenn wir das auf die lage auf
die so die subjektförderung sozusagen
wie wir das nennen würden organisieren
also dann an die situation der haushalte
und nicht in den markt eingreifen wir
müssen ja irgendwann auch schauen dass
diese preissignale sukzessive sich
normalisieren wir gehen ja schon davon
aus wenn die anpassungen laufen dass
dann die gaspreise in ein zwei jahren
auch eine andere dimension haben aber im
augenblick ist es halt so wir haben
einen wohlstands abschluss ins ausland
das ist schlicht und ausland um gerade
so sind wir beim thema
haushaltseinkommen und damit auch bei
der frage wie man durch lohnerhöhungen
dieses haushaltseinkommen verbessern
kann wernicke es gibt ja ganz
unterschiedliche branchen brauchen sie
sehr gut verdienen die auch kräftige
lohnerhöhungen an ihren mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter zahlen können und es
gibt branchen die sie möglicherweise
sogar vor dem aus stehen oder wo viele
unternehmen fast wanken wie
differenziert wie flexibel wie
spezifiziert muster die lohn
tarifpolitik der gewerkschaften sein da
wir im wesentlichen für
branchentarifverträge abschließen muss
und wird auf unterschiedliche branchen
situationen immer reflektiert ist
überhaupt keine neue erfahrung sondern
das ist ja der grundsatz von
tarifpolitik derzeit haben eine
situation wenn ich mal auf die
dienstleistungsbranchen schaue wo
während krassen arbeitskräftemangel
haben eine überlastung situation in
vielen vielen bereichen die flughäfen
sind da nur die spitze des eisberges
gleichzeitig verdienen in den
dienstleistungsbranchen unternehmen
weiterhin gutes geld die preiserhöhung
werden an die kunden weitergegeben noch
etwas draufgelegt von da gibt es aus
meiner sicht überhaupt gar kein grund
für diese bereiche eine tarifpolitik mit
angezogener handbremse zu machen weil
kaufkraftverluste vermieden werden
müssen wir haben dort derzeit keine
krisensituation wie die welt aussieht
wenn der gashahn abgedreht wird und
welche folgewirkungen sich dann von der
industrie in anderen branchen
hineinziehen das muss man dann sehen
aber derzeit haben wir keine
krisensituation in den branchen dich
geschildert habe jetzt ein unternehmen
hier vertreten sie leben mit wir müssen
leben mit hohen rohstoff halbseitig
wahren kosten bedrohen lieferkosten mit
hohen produktionskosten hohen
energiekosten welche rolle spielt da
spielen da die lohnkosten in ihrem
unternehmen die dann noch dazu kommen
also wie gesagt die die kostenbelastung
des unternehmens insgesamt wird ja immer
größer welche rolle spielen da die
lohnkosten also die tarifverhandlungen
sind als nächstes jahr das von daher ist
es ein nebenkriegsschauplatz weniger dem
ihr aktueller aber grundsätzlich schauen
wir natürlich auch darauf wie sich das
entwickeln wird wir wissen dass die
forderungen entsprechend hoch sein
werden und ich bin mir sicher dass wir
uns mit der gewerkschaft gut einigen
werden so dass beide seiten etwas davon
haben dass beide seiten damit gut leben
können oder dass beide seiten damit
gleichermaßen schlecht leben können das
ist dann je nachdem von wie man das
betrachtet aber
nochmal weise auch die frage gestellt
haben mit welche branchen sind besonders
betroffen oder in welchen branchen kann
man sich das leisten in einem
internationalen umfeld hat nur mit
konkurriert mit mit ländern da gibt es
ganz unterschiedliche bedingungen also
wir können das nicht außer acht lassen
wir haben eine exportquote von 80
prozent also wir als unternehmen unsere
konkreten sitzen in frankreich spanien
in asien in lateinamerika usa also der
kunde wartet nicht ewig aktuell
akzeptierte das noch aktuell versteht er
das noch aber es wird der moment kommen
wo auch die kunden abwandern sich
überlegen wo kann ich denn günstiger
produzieren lassen und deswegen dürfen
wir das nicht außer acht lassen bei
allen möglichen warnung nicht nur tree
verhandlungen sondern auch eben
natürlich gas und ähnlicher ist als will
kommt es zu der lohn preis spirale im
moment in diesem jahr wahrscheinlich
nicht nur wir haben weil lohnforderungen
liegen bei 78 dann wird man
üblicherweise eher weniger weiß das
besser als ich bei 4 bis 5 prozent
abschließen bei einer ein klares
inflation von 8 hat man immer noch einen
reallohnverlust auf der uhr wenn man
eben weil wir eine gesuchte eine
kompromisslinie von werde jetzt hier
nicht verkünden aber die frage des
ebenfalls im nächsten jahr passiert was
23 passiert wenn man dann eben eine
inflationsrate von 5 prozent hat wenn
die forderung dann wieder 80 prozent
sind und man bei fünf oder sechs prozent
ab schließt also ob es eine
lohn-preis-spirale gibt das weiß man
jetzt noch nicht es gibt die gefahr
einer in diesem jahr sieht es noch nicht
so aus
wir sind beim thema gas und gas krise
zum abschluss der sendung würde ich
ihnen gern noch eine grafik zeigen und
zwar das sogenannte gasspeicher gesetz
das nämlich vorsieht dass wir im
november bei 90% fünf ständen in unseren
gasspeichern sein müssen die dicke linie
die zeigt den aktuellen füllstand im
juli im august soll das jahr etwa 65
prozent seien im oktober 80 und dann im
dezember oder november dann 90 prozent
dann werde kämen wir einigermaßen über
den winter die gestrichelten gezeigt die
wir in den letzten jahren da
abgeschnitten haben als im moment nähern
wir uns wieder den durchschnitt der
letzten jahre
herr hüther diese ziele die wir da
gesehen haben mit den 90 prozent im
dezember wir haben es dann jetzt überall
auf der welt gas ist dieses vorhaben ist
die sind diese ziele die wir gerade
gesehen haben noch haltbar
sind dann haltbar wenn nach der
wartungsfristen aus dem einst wieder in
die volle leistungsfähigkeit geht dann
können wir diese speicher auffüllen man
muss ja einfach mal sehen dass die
politik aber auch die verantwortlichen
haben wir im ganzen jahr 20 21 nicht zur
kenntnis genommen dass die speicher
nicht befüllt wurden und das ist ja von
russland vorbereitet worden die
problemlage über die wir hier heute
abend diskutieren und frieden im land
und seit langem und insofern ja das ist
jetzt deutlich vorangekommen wir sind
bei den 60 prozent das kann uns auch
gelingen das federt uns dann ab in das
nächste jahr hinein
schwierig wird es eigentlich dann noch
mal 23 auf 24 denn der
fortschrittsbericht energiesicherheit
des bundeswirtschaftsministers zeigt uns
ja dass auch 2024 noch etwa zehn prozent
des anteils den wir brauchen oder des
gases wir brauchen aus russland benötigt
wird also wir kommen so ganz schnell
nicht daraus und die gasmengen die wir
in der welt ordern können müssen wir es
mehr bekommt es ist schon so dass wir
gar nicht die schiffs kapazität rangers
haben wir haben auch nicht wirklich die
verladung kapazität und die die
umwandlungsquote in den usa das heißt
wenn die usa wirklich die
energiepartnerschaft mit europa in dem
thema führen will müssen sie auch selbst
in entsprechende infrastrukturen
investieren es reicht ja nicht wenn wir
hier terminals haben und gucken aus
überaus der welt das jetzt her kommen
ist bleibt dann auch ein mengenproblem
gut und einer dieser verladeterminals im
texas der brennt auch gerade was kein
gutes zeichen für das für die weitere
versorgung ist das land werden wir
jedenfalls noch jede menge sendungen
haben zu diesem thema ich bedanke mich
bei michael hüther bei ursula weidenfeld
bei frank werneke und beim rataj über
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
von krise zu krise hat scholz die lage
im griff morgen befragung der
bundesregierung also befragung des
bundeskanzlers im bundestag und da geht
es nicht nur um die gaskrise bleiben sie
bei uns
[Musik]